mr. Keller  mr. Roberts to be my 9 o'clock do you  think stop over the bank for 5 minutes  can't stop the car  sorry  what did you just tell what did we just  I can't do this I can't be involved if I  write God why doesn't anybody listen  get in partner I'm not your partner and  I'll shoot you have fun in jail okay  rubber bullet I use it for when I'm  mildly pissed off I use these when I'm  serious let's go let's do it inside this  case is nine million dollars you get me  to where I want to go three of it is  yours kind of stupid do you think  kind of bank did you rob well they're  not a bag so they're you recognize the  definitional work those aren't  guy  good afternoon are you here for the  reception listen Dan you better be  careful with that grandmother she's a  nice old lady